The recall, the cases when it's truly Bush, and
we recognize it's Bush, is 123 over 127, which resolves to about .97, 97%.
Where as the precision for George W.
Bush, that's this column over here.
In my calculations 123 over 156,
which is the sum of all the predictions of George W.
Bush. And that resolves to about 0.79.
Much lower.
Whether this warrants a recall for George W.
Bush, is an open question, but you can see the asymmetry.
This specific learning algorithm is really good in recalling or
finding George W.
Bush, provided that it's actually Bush in the image.
But it mistakes many, many other people.
Most notably Colin Powell and Donald Rumsfeld for George W.
Bush.